first of all the lockdown is it likely
to be extended yes Adam its most likely
to be extend in fact one of the states
because we are in a federal structure
states can take take responsibility of
the areas and and extend it and one of
the states has already extended it to
the 30th a number of other states will
follow suit
there the the government has intensified
its its fight against the virus now they
have set up about 1200 containment zones
and these zones are in varying in sizes
in sort of apartment blocks or streets
or or even districts where thousands and
thousands of people are living and these
will be sealed and police officers and
health health officials will be at the
entry and exit gates all essential
products of our items like food milk
water medicines will be delivered
door-to-door health workers will be
checking homes and and residents in
their houses for any symptoms and those
found will be found with any symptoms
will be tested and then further action
will be taken the government coming down
and and now trying to contain this virus
to spread to other people from people
who have tested positive as of now India
has been testing very very low numbers
were one of the lowest in the world at
the moment and the government taking
taking no you know taking all measures
including the national lockdown with
this new containment zones across the
country